mirror mirror on the wall which youtuber
is the fairest of them all I mean which
theorist is fairest of them all
okay sure that's true but which male
theorist is fairest of them all come on
hello Internet
welcome to film Theory the place where
kids at heart never have to grow up kind
of like Toys R Us but without the creepy
giraffe guy now if I've said it once
I've said it a thousand times I love
Disney so much so that I just got a
bumper sticker attesting to it that is
commitment my friends now while I love
the recent stuff obviously since I've
covered everything from the questionable
sisterhood of Anna and Elsa to a fish
who just so happens to forget things
when it's most convenient for her we've
got to give credit to the classics too
and when I say the classics I mean the
most classic Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs the og feature-length animated
film coming out in 1937 which by the way
was a whole decade before televisions
went on sale fun fact
Snow White was such a monumental moment
in movie history that at the Academy
Awards it won a special honorary Oscar
for being so innovative getting itself
one large statue and seven tiny ones
eight statues for one category that
didn't even exist now that is called
winning no I recently rewatched Snow
White and somehow it's a lot more
intense than I remember hey there mr.
Huntsman my teenage stepdaughter is
getting a little too pretty so would you
do me a solid and wore her out into the
woods and you know rip her heart out man
and here we all thought that Zootopia
being an allegory for racism was risque
it also tell that I've been making these
videos for a little too long because
instead of just sitting back and you
know enjoying the movie I saw tons of
unanswered questions just write for the
theorising like why Seven Dwarves just
so happen to have a coffin line
let alone a coffin made of glass let
alone one that would fit a normal-sized
person I mean are they in the habit of
burying full-sized humans on the rag
we're how about the fact that the
prince's first instinct when he sees a
dead girl lying in the forest is to
pucker up seriously bro number one
corpse germs and number two corpse germs
but the moment that really got my gears
a turnin was the scene where the Queen
makes the poisoned apple all she calls
her brew is the same but we don't see
what really goes into it and it's such
an iconic fairy tale and movie staple
that it prompted my question of the day
which is is it possible to create a
weaponized fruit that behaves in the way
that we see it Snow White I figured
after making episodes about nuclear
weapons
hacking government drug conspiracies
that all my Google searches are being
monitored anyways so researching deadly
fruits seems tame by comparison let's do
this
so obviously this has to be an apple
dipped into some sort of fast-acting
poison like the deadliest candy apple
known to man but what sort of poison is
it well remember that Snow White takes a
single bite and then soon afterwards
says that she's feeling a bit strange
yeah thanks a lot for the help of the
symptoms snowy but Web MD doesn't have a
diagnosis for feeling strange shortly
thereafter she passes out to lie in a
coma before reviving so the biggest
thing that stands out about the poison
Apple is how fast it knocks out Snow
White and this led me to first consider
a poison famous for going fast
cyanide cyanide is an extremely
concentrated poison so concentrated in
fact that if you're a 200-pound man it
would take a dose of cyanide about half
the size of an aspirin to kill you
cyanide is also perhaps most famous as
the poison of choice for spies and
secret agents during World War 2 the
Allied forces created a suicide pill
they called the L pill for agents going
behind enemy lines the pill which was
filled with cyanide was about the size
of a pea and agents were supposed to
bite into it if they were caught behind
enemy lines so that they could die
without suffering torture and
interrogation
so is cyanide a likely culprit
the poisoned Apple well at first it
might seem so as cyanide is readily
available in natural products like
almonds and fittingly enough apple seeds
with that said and all these natural
products the traces of cyanide are very
very low you need to eat well over 10
pounds of almonds to get a lethal dose
and to get a more concentrated dosage
like the one found in 2l pill you're
gonna need to do some chemical treatment
in a lab and that's a problem because no
wait the Seven Dwarves is set in a time
that's pre electricity so I think it's
safe to assume that the Queen isn't
doing much enzyme extraction in that
little lab of hers besides it Snow White
had cyanide poisoning she might have
passed out that fast but there ain't no
way she's getting back up a cyanide
dosage like the one found in the L pill
is enough to make a person brain dead in
a matter of minutes and the rest of the
way dead shortly thereafter no matter
how long that creepy Prince makeout sesh
goes she ain't getting back up cyanide
is safely off the list so what we really
need is a poison strong enough for a man
but made for a woman or more accurately
a poison strong enough to put her into a
coma but not so deadly that she has no
chance of coming out of it call me crazy
but could Snow White be
not like a Walking Dead 28 days later
first things first I'll eat your brains
kind of zombie but an actual Haitian
voodoo zombie in his 1985 book the
serpent in the rainbow Harvard
ethnobotanist Wade Davis examines a case
of Haitian zama fication and describes
the process by which a voodoo shaman
called a book or poison someone and
buries him only to bring him back to
life when that poison wears off Davis
cites in his book tetrodotoxin a
powerful neurotoxin as the main culprit
and knocking the victim out the source
of the tetrodotoxin is a pufferfish
which any ardent fan of The Simpsons
knows has the capacity to be fatal
poison poison tasty fish and
tetrodotoxin is definitely strong strong
enough to send you into a coma with very
small dose or kill you with one that's
slightly larger but it's here that we
run into our problem geography
tetrodotoxin is found in a variety of
sea creatures but which all of them and
especially the puffer fish are found in
tropical climates the movie version of
Snow White and the Seven Dwarves never
explicitly tells us where we are but
considering that Snow White the Seven
Dwarves is coming from the Brothers
Grimm fairy tales
is probably taking place in southern
Germany since that's where they were
from and where they based most of their
stories additionally if you look at the
landscape of forests and mountains the
architecture of the Evil Queen's castle
and even the animals present throughout
the movie they're all indicators that
were in Germany or close by long story
short the likelihood of the Queen
getting her hands on an exotic
pufferfish especially in the
pre-industrial era is just too big of a
stretch
so to recap even though the Apple scene
and Snow White is really short we
actually know a lot about it from the
contact clues we need a fast-acting
poison that with a single small bite is
gonna be powerful enough to cause a coma
but not so powerful as to guarantee
death it has to be easily found in
nature since the Evil Queen doesn't have
any breaking bad as lab equipment for
distilling down the poison and it also
must be indigenous to Central Europe
well after scouring the internet and
following a ton of leads I finally have
the killer who meets all our
requirements say hello to a tropa
belladona also known as deadly
nightshade deadly nightshade grows in
the wild and is most notable for its
shiny dark blue-black berries which are
sometimes mistaken for non-toxic
blueberries or elderberries crucial
mistake and it just so happens to check
off every detail on our list Snow White
is poisoned by just a single bite of
that Apple so the poison needs to be
potent well the lethal dose for an adult
is usually in the neighborhood of 10 to
20 of these little berries considering
that Snow White is small and young it's
safe to assume something on the lower
end would kill her though remember we
just want to knock her out not outright
kill her to a bite of that coated Apple
would be just about the right dosage
which also begs the question can a tropa
belladona actually put you in a coma
while you're picking the right berries
because it sure can non lethal doses of
deadly nightshade caused a wide range of
symptoms from heart palpitations to
hallucinations a first-person account of
non lethal belladonna poisoning from
2015 reported that the first thing the
person wanted to do was go to sleep
which was then followed by vivid
hallucinations the nap fits Snow White's
condition perfectly and surprisingly so
did the hallucinations of course in the
animated movie the only information that
we ever get from Snow White is that she
feels strange and collapses immediately
but for more information we can turn to
the Disney ABC series once upon a time
yes I watch it and yes I'm just as
annoyed as you are that the crew still
trusts Rumbles
all skin come on oh sorry I've had that
building over the last couple years I
had to get it off my chest anyway in
that series we actually get to see what
it's like inside snows mind when she's
under one of these sleeping curses and
what we see is that victims of the
sleeping death are shown to experience
some crazy visual nightmares after being
poisoned
just like the vivid hallucinations
caused by deadly nightshade but there's
even more one thing that we haven't
considered yet is held a poisoned case
you'd think that if snow-white bent into
the Apple and it tasted weird she would
either spit it out or say something like
it not tasting like an apple kind of
like Apple Jacks
[Music]
for instance if Walter White had made
the Apple for snow and coated it in his
favorite poison ricin ricin contains
castor oil which would make the Apple
taste bitter and well not like an apple
signaling to snow that her bite was a
bit off but as poisons go deadly
nightshade actually tastes relatively
good people who have eaten belladona
berries report that it has a pleasant
mildly sweet flavor just like most other
fruits and berries and that's important
if you're trying to make sure that your
victim doesn't get suspicious of your
Apple and lastly Atropa belladonna makes
a whole lot of sense in the geographical
and historical context of the story
Atropa belladonna is native to southern
and Central Europe including the
southern part of Germany so location is
a definite fit and Atropa belladonna was
historically a very popular poison in
European history around the time Snow
White was sat in the 11th century the
Scottish King Macbeth yeah that Macbeth
he was real used a trope a belladona to
poison an army of invading danes it's
even believed that deadly nightshade was
used to kill the Roman Emperor Claudius
back in 54 ad clearly this poison would
have been known about and prevalent at
the time in other words every last
detail in Snow White in the Seven
Dwarves points to a trove of belladonna
has the poison in the poisoned Apple but
I'm not done there's still one massive
problem and it's one I'm sure that all
of you are thinking right now if Snow
White had been poisoned by a very
dangerous potentially deadly toxin like
those found in a tropa belladona how is
she cured by the princes kiss the short
answer is she's not boom mind blown drop
in the my
screw true love's kiss all your gonna
wind up with his corpse germs nope my
loyal theorists it wasn't love that
saved the fair maiden it was chemistry
Atropa belladonna poisoning has a few
popular antidotes one of which is
activated carbon no activated carbon is
essentially charcoal dust that absorbs
toxins in the body swallow some
activated carbon activated carbon draws
the toxins from your system and absorbs
them and then poof those toxins no
longer damage your body now Snow White
obviously didn't intentionally swallow
any activated carbon pills but she has
been in contact with it from the moment
she entered the forest how the dwarves
it's the dwarf remember these guys work
underground in a diamond mine and a
diamond is nothing more than a bunch of
carbon put under intense pressure
in fact it's established earlier in the
movie that when the dwarves come home
they're always covered in dirt and soot
so much so that Snow White has to
convince them to wash off before they
eat so all that cleaning she does all
that time she's spending with the
dwarves she's inhaling activated carbon
it's already in her system then Snow
White eats the Apple gets poison and
gets sent into a state of sleeping death
from there the dwarves once again
covered in carbon soot from the mines
carry her off to the glass coffin along
the way she inhales even more carbon and
all along the way the carbon in her
system is slowing the absorption of the
toxins until finally enough has been
drawn out of her system that she's able
to wake up that's right
Snow White wasn't cured by Love's first
kiss or some doofy corpse germy Prince
no she was cured by none other than the
Seven Dwarves now remember kids an apple
a day may keep the doctor away but an
apple covered in deadly nightshade it's
just gonna kill you but hey that's just
a theory a film theory
nice now that I've ruined a classic
fairytale trope I hope you're ready for
more old-school childhood ruining Disney
fury action because it's time to click
this poison Apple right here and have
the Lion King get utterly wrecked for
you that's wrecked with an R ekt which
means you know I'm serious my friends
over on the wisecrack channel did an
incredible analysis of The Lion King
which gets you to really question
whether scar is all that evil to begin
with
who are the true bad guys here in that
movie because at its core it's a story
of the haves and the have-nots and scar
is just advocating on behalf of the
little guys it completely changed the
way that I look at that movie and I'm
sure you'll have the same reaction so
click that Apple and go have the Lion
King get poison for you and hey if you
liked what you saw in this episode click
here to subscribe we've got a lot of
awesome theories planned for the final
months of the year with some big-name
titles like Star Wars and Pixar so
you're not gonna want to miss a theory
especially the wall-e one that's coming
out in two weeks here click and
subscribe then go watch The Lion King
wisecrack video and if you do both of
those things you'll have made two
fantastic decisions today well 3
actually because he chose to watch this
video in the first place so three
fantastic decisions today your brain
will thank you and I'll make you just a
cooler person on the whole now if you'll
excuse me I feel something strange
brewing that one's for next week see you
then
[Music]